what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back again with another episode of
our beyond omega level series yes where
we basically tell you guys everything
you need to know about the most powerful
characters and comics and today we're
focusing on one of the elder gods of the
marvel universe cathone
and there are a couple of different
issues that could be cited as the first
appearance of catholic the first is
marvel chillers number one by marv
wolfman and bill mantlow which was
released in 1975 and i didn't even know
that book existed until we started doing
this video but in that book cathone was
simply referred to as the other it
wasn't until 1979 when avengers number
186 by mark gruenwald david micolini and
john byrne came out that he was actually
referred to as catholic now within the
marvel continuity cathode's been around
for billions of years and the source of
his existence is a sentient life force
on earth known as the demiurge so
basically what happened here is that at
some point in the past the demiurge
created a group of elder gods that
included catholic and with the exception
of gaia who's basically mother earth in
the marvel universe and is also the
mother of thor all the elder gods became
demons once one of them a guy named seth
basically figured out that he could
increase his power by eating his
siblings and then the rest of them all
just followed suit and so cathone
basically became the embodiment of
darkness on earth and the world's first
practitioner of dark magic now when gaia
in the demiurge touched naughty bits and
produced a son named atum he basically
began killing the elder gods and
absorbing their powers and so cathone
writes down all his knowledge of dark
magic into an indestructible book called
the dark hold which he would leave
behind on earth while he escaped to
another dimension now following that
cathode produced an entire race of
demonic offspring known as the angari
and would also act through the other to
impact things on earth through those who
use the dark hole including bringing
about the first vampires in the marvel
universe now anytime someone used the
dark hole cathone could use their soul
to try and return to earth and over the
billions of years he's impacted events
on earth by sending various minions to
earth when the dimensional barrier
between his dimension and earth are weak
enough now cathode is also summoned to
earth by morgan le faye in the 6th
century but after realizing how powerful
he was she and merlin tried to banish
him back to his dimension but they were
unable to get the job done and had to
lock part of catholic's essence away and
what would one day be one degor mountain
where the high evolutionary would build
his citadel of science in the 1930s now
later a man named gregor rusoff who was
secretly a werewolf summoned cathode to
cure him buccathon tried to return to
earth and while he was repelled by the
knights of wonder gore cathone managed
to bond himself to a nearby infant that
would turn out to be wanda maximoff the
scarlet witch and so cathome would later
possess wanda's brother quicksilver but
hank pym and the avengers were able to
exercise custom and send him back to his
home dimension once again and so as far
as his powers go cathone is stupidly
powerful to the point that he borders on
omnipotence especially in his own realm
where he's able to exercise total
dominion over all of that reality he's
essentially the source for basically all
of the dark magic in the world including
chaos magic which has empowered its
users to perform ridiculously incredible
feats the most notable example of this
is scarlet witch who catholine had
imbued with the ability to perform chaos
magic in an attempt to make her his
avatar and return to earth by possessing
her and while wielding chaos magic
scarlet witch was able to bend reality
to her will casting spells that affected
countless individuals dimensions and
realities and this is just a fraction of
what cathode himself is actually capable
of in fact cathode calls the scarlet
witch a shadow of being who is still
very much beneath me and he's talking
about someone who'd eliminated nearly
every mutant in the marvel universe with
three words and took all their powers
away now cathone's mystic abilities have
no known limits and are incredibly
impressive even when working through a
conduit for example when he was
possessing quicksilver cathode managed
to flood new york city with a river of
blood trapped the entire city of san
francisco in a block of amber and
relocate asgard to a different dimension
he also melted vibranium turned the
young avengers to stone and the
fantastic four into television signals
so we're pretty much talking high-level
reality warping and matter manipulation
here and while possessing quicksilver
cathode stated that all of reality would
fall before him in the blink of an eye
and once again that's only whatever
fraction of catholic's power his host
was able to harness and so in terms of
how cathode compares to some really
really powerful beings in marvel comics
eternity refers to cathone as a cancer
and states that he would have been able
to kill eternity had hank pym not
interfered and as a reward for saving
reality eternity names him the scientist
supreme of earth so the fact that
cathone was a threat to eternity quite
literally the embodiment of all of
reality lets us know just how
potentially devastating this guy is and
to add a bit more context and this one's
really going to blow your mind dormammu
one of the strongest magic users in the
marvel universe invokes cathone when
casting spells suggesting that he's
actually drawing on getthone's power
which would theoretically mean that
cathode is on a higher plane of
existence than dormammu who is himself
way beyond omega level but that's
basically what you need to know about
this guy i mean i'd be shocked if he
doesn't show up in the mcu sometime soon
because he's just such a big part of
scarlet witch's story in the comics so
when he does you'll know everything that
you need to know about him and rest
assured if the marvel cinematic universe
takes cathode from the comics and rolls
him over in the mcu movies and he's
anywhere near as powerful as he is in
the comics thanos with the infinity
gauntlet has nothing on this guy with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this to an end thank you guys for
watching and i will catch you all later
peace